une série télé réalité tout ce qu'on ne
vous a jamais montré moi c'est sylvie
jehl manager un groupe de boys band avec
200 milles vu sur internet aussi bovins
j'ai produit des groupes congolais
salut moi c'est farm coach officiel de
patrice lavoie glisser un chanteur muet
mais quand son single va sortir tu as à
faire du bruit
c'est parti allait envoyer le premier
bonjour moi c'est 100 de pierres ou des
centres gavin le lift humour bardot sont
des vignes du film au bout c'est un
petit village dans l'est de montréal si
on vous écoute on parle bien des
ateliers jeunes hommes vous pouvez pas
chanter dans une langue du tiers monde
du tiers monde sache encore ce monsieur
ouais je jouais pas sur les mots venez
passer l'été en corse
vous serez les bienvenus je passais mes
vacances en tunisie moi bonjour massés
samedi aux bahamas m
et plus que peu progressé 1
j'ai vraiment été touchée vous êtes
sélectionneur fait quoi à vie si google
pourquoi tu vends bonjour nourri cet
arrêt venez me love vous asseoir à ma
table et ses bouffées rémy lors être les
biens vos aises voter oui merci merci
vraiment pas mal un peu cheap le web
s'il vous plaît master en économie
pourquoi non ce soit pas possible merci
mademoiselle mais celle-ci vraiment bien
pourquoi n'a pas prise mais attention là
pour le valeur des contrats mais qu'est
ce que vous foutez là la sécurité c'est
au premier non je vais passer le cast et
pardon à l'asie
pourquoi tu regarde toi c'est tout va
bien ce que je fais je pressens que les
chefs je sais combien de temps ça m'a
pris non c'était c'était vraiment super
voilà michael jackson des bonjour
bonjour malaisie présentez-vous très
drôle ah ça c'est drôle ça c'est une
blague en hockey je m'appelle olemps et
et de verre oui oh arrêtez votre cinéma
au gie par la non mais c'est sa cinéma
non mais parce que mes fait pas de bile
seul homme ils sont sérieux de verre
patrick dewaere percuté à cesser le
tennisman mais non pas tennisman patrick
dewaere de comédiens les valseuses série
noire
miou-miou gérard depardieu je sais pas
moi ok ok allez dire on vous écoute là
c'est à dire je ne sais pas vous êtes
venus chanter passer un casting
non mais je n'ai pas cette enquête mais
pourquoi madame ne passe pas de casting
j'ai été nominée aux césars et mlle
banon alors tu dégages salanon des
quotas or death te plaît non mais foutez
moi corps à lyon vous filera déplacent
près dans le public d'accord attendez
c'est quoi cette histoire de quotas tu
sais très bien la ménagère de moins de
50 ans il ya trop d'arabes et le pompon
eh ben on va quand même l'écouter
allez-y alors je m'appelle jean françois
comment hergé
hervé momo très bien membres asie
quand cela arrive à cannes the sky et
comme tu y es jolie comme ça avec que
tes petits yeux là là c'est fini
salut salut
wesh cousin bien au quattro que la
famille je peux tout va bien les
présentez vous là moi c'est jason jeunes
carcassonne tu veux me tattevin résonne
du crime bouffonne papa papa papa c'est
frais c'est lourd c'est des doses vous
avez toute votre place dans notre
émission à laisse ainsi la famille vas-y
retiens mon plage des zones jason-1 ou
merci on est là vas-y bouvin je te kiffe
ah non désolé cousine on a déjà notre
quota ne porte quoi va les y est
d'ailleurs même pas la peine nous est
revenue talent ça me choque
oui la peace love you
très bien une petite question qu'est ce
que vous comptez faire musicalement
après l'émission je me [ __ ] à poil
dans les magazines qui poule je vais
faire des fausses paparazzades et
surtout surtout je veux faire une fac on
vous remercie
tu vas bonjour c'est vrai il réside
brillant vous écoute
grand loto de l'univers vous est pris tu
es génial vraiment suivant bonjour moi
c'est dany je vais vous chanter une
chanson qui s'appelle ziggy de céline
dion isabelle ziggy je suis folle de lui
c'est un garçon très bien vous êtes vous
êtes sélectionné c'est super mais celui
là était vraiment mauvais pour qu'on l'a
pris il est plaqué pelles et si je le
pompage et teddy riner eric et sur le
dos